well one of the most frequently asked
questions as far as language learning is
concerned is without a doubt the
following there's a lot of people ask me
Luca did you ever learn more languages
at the same time and how do you go about
it now I think that in general everybody
could learn more than one language at a
time as possible nobody nobody can
forbid you from can keep you hamper you
from from doing that at the same time
though I think that choosing more than
one language at the same time is
something that you have to think about
cautiously you think you have to think
about quite a lot before doing that
because there's a lot of factors
involved as far as I'm concerned until
recently until 2008 late 2008 2009 I
never learned more than one language at
a time and the first time that I
actually dealt with two languages was
with Chinese and Portuguese the main
reason why I didn't I always constantly
learned just one language at a time is
mainly due to the fact that first I I
was never in a hurry to learn foreign
languages secondly once they chose a
language I was so interested in that one
that I I didn't care about the others it
was just that one I was just courting
that one girl and so to say and learning
one language at a time gave me the
possibility to to concentrate to focus
on that given language and that was very
important for me because as I will say
later the problem especially as far as
the first six months are concerned is
always to build a core that's the main
goal six months one year two
the difficulty of the language now I
wrote a couple of things here but don't
worry about it you can find them on you
can find the article on my blog I would
just to make a video to make it more
entertaining
I just wanted to before delving into
this problem you know the technical
details I just wanted to tell you three
main factors that she you have to think
of when you want to learn two three four
languages at the same time the first one
is that haste is your worst enemy
I think personally think that money the
modern world is obsessed with here and
now compulsion which is particularly
harmful to language learning it means
that you there's a lot of people who ask
me this is another very common question
how can I learn a language quickly is
there any shortcuts well in English
Italian as far as other languages you
can find a lot of sentences like goin
steady wins the race
haste is a bet counselor and there's a
lot of light and Latin sayings as well
because actually the you know that's
true haste is you know the the worst
fiend for for quality that's what I
think at least as I said before the
first three six nine months are very
important and especially the beginning
quality and quality work is absolutely
essential for the rest of for the for
the future outcome so I think that haste
and keep saying that haste is your worst
enemy so learn things step by step not
necessarily super slowly but
consistently and do it every day and
don't worry about
about the feature just concentrate and
focus on the moment on secondly building
a language core is the most important
thing for every learner building a
language core it means that we build a
net in our head it is not just a matter
of accumulating words it is also a
matter of putting them together give
them a phonetic tress so to say so it is
the main goal is to to build a net in
your head it means that once you have
built that net you are able to speak the
language more or less you have the
language inside you and even if you
don't speak it that much in the future
you quickly go back to it just with a
little practice that's the meaning of
building a core building a core means to
have a general grasp and understanding
of how the language works and it means
that it's ingrained in your brain in
order to build a language core you have
to focus very much on one language the
problem of the core is that as I said
before it's not just a matter of words
grammar and pronunciation but it is also
a matter of emotions colors you know you
remember when you start to learn a
language there was a period of your life
so everything is its entangled with
emotions emotions and grammar with
colors and words it's everything is put
together and it forms the so called core
if you learn two three four languages at
the same time your risk that you run the
risk you seriously run the risk of
mixing things together and you don't
want to do that thirdly is it is
probably the most obvious here its
optimizing your time we I think that
time schedules Airport in language
learning it is not just a matter of what
things you do what actions
you do but also how and when you do it
the Disco the so-called time schedule
now in the article that I wrote them and
you can read it on my blog I compared to
students student a and student B and
they both want to learn ten languages
within ten years one goes for two
languages over two years so studies for
example on an old French and German and
then he's Italian let's suppose the the
student both students are Italian let's
suppose a student a wants to learn you
know German and French for the first two
years if you if if he can just focus in
two languages which is already not bad
you know two languages is a big quantity
as far as I'm concerned and then he
spends these two years focusing on these
two languages then at the end of the
second year he he decides to learn say
Swedish and Chinese so why can do is
that him after two years he has already
a very good grasp of the first two
languages that he had been learning so
what happens is that in this way he can
actually start learning other languages
while perfecting the ones he had
previously learned and he can do it over
two years at the end of the ten years he
will not keep he will probably be able
to speak for five languages very well
and the other ones he will dabbling as
those language all we'll speak them
probably not as well it's normal he will
not have the same level in all his ten
languages but he will have built a core
in four or five and this is the main
goal student B thinks that it's better
it's a wise choice to go for ten
languages at the same time because he
thinks he can spare time so he just
learns tell languages every day but even
if he wanted to learn say six or four
four languages every day's a lot so it
means that you have to divide your time
schedule your energy and you're actually
not focusing on anything in particular
at
the end of the ten years he will
probably have built a core in a couple
language but it isn't it there are very
few language learners who are able to
learn ten languages for turning ten
years every day every single day there
will be days where he forgets to do this
homework or there will be days where it
doesn't he just doesn't want to do it so
if you have 10 years 5 years certain
time budget I strongly suggest to us to
stick to one or two languages and then
once you have built a core to move on to
learning others this is what I've been
doing for the last 20 years more or less
and I think it paid off well hopefully
now the last part of this of this video
is on tips and guidance for learning
multiple languages at the same time I
think that if you want to go for more
than to know more than one language that
is two or three multiple languages at
the same time I would suggest these
things first of all if you have the
following if you have a fair amount of
time to dedicate to language learning
will power some experience and language
learning and good time management skills
these are the four factors key factors
that for learning multiple languages at
the same time if you decide to take on
this multi language challenge here are
when I think some useful tips first
choose a maximum of two languages at any
given time three languages is already
too much as far as I'm concerned and
will impair whatever language core you
are trying to build so two languages max
second choose a length two languages
that are possibly different from each
other languages that are similar can
overlap in so many ways so in
words grammar and as I said even
emotions and memories as well as other
factors so it obviously causes confusion
so what do you think for example
learning Spanish and Italian if you're a
native English speaker or Dutch and
German as far as I'm concerned it's not
a good idea
third try to choose an easy language and
relatively difficult one and by easy and
difficult I always refer to the fact
that there are easy or difficult and
related you know in relationship with
your own native tongue for native
English speaker Dutch would be an easy
language and Chinese would be a
difficult one for example and fourth if
you choose two languages that are at a
fairly opposite ends of the complexity
scale try to give 80% dedicate 80% of
your time to the difficult one and 20%
of the time to the easy one that's what
he did for example - as far as Chinese
and Portuguese are concerned for
cheetah's was very easy I mean no
language is extremely easy but I have to
say that Portuguese was a matter of
mainly a matter of adjusting your
pronunciation changing a little bit from
the Spanish version of Spanish so 80% -
the difficult one in 20% and to dedicate
it to the easy one and you first do to
first learn the difficult one so 80% and
then at the end of the section the
easier one you deal with the easy one
and fifth is to study both languages
every single day every single day okay
because it is extremely important so I
just wanted to tell you once again
language learning is not a race it's a
marathon that you do with yourself so if
you put time if you put
quality work and you've put patience you
will reach your goal no matter what
happens so these are just a few tips
hope that you liked the video and more
videos are coming by